this is working
okay i think i'm live
oh my gosh
okay let's see i need someone to come in
here and tell me if you guys can like
hear me okay
okay it looks like there's like five
people in here guys this is my first
time
like doing this so
i'm gonna react to some kevin samuels
but
can you guys like chat i think you can
okay
yeah it's a live stream so i want to
know can you guys hear
i'm going to tap on my microphone
because i want to see if um
you guys can hear me like from the
microphone so i'm going to tap on it
will you guys let me know if you can
hear it
[Music]
alright did you guys hear that i just
tapped on it
let me know let me know
sorry this is my first time like live
streaming i'm trying to make this like a
regular thing so i'm trying to make sure
it's picked up
okay pre-recorded
i wish um i actually don't really know
how to pre-record anything
um so
i'm just curious can you guys
so go live enable live streaming
can you guys like see my screen you can
just see me
right i'm trying to figure out how to
make it so you guys can see my screen
too because right now i do
not think you can
um stream
um wait sorry
um did you guys see say that you can see
my screen or you can't
just put in the comment like i can see
your stream screen or i can't see your
screen because
i like don't know how to work this stuff
yet um
now you can only see you okay how
because i wanted to like match up with
okay i'm gonna end this only because i
want to figure out how to make it so you
guys can see my screen
and right now i can't figure that out um
am i lagging before i go last question
am i lagging
like um i want to make sure the internet
connection's cool up here that you guys
can actually like
like the internet connection is good
enough for you guys to like keep up
okay so guys this isn't pre-recorded
look it's 328.
okay i'm gonna end the live and see if i
can fix it i'll be back